meet mirai a short and cute girl who
wears red glasses however despite her
appearance this young lady is carrying a
heavy burden as the last surviving
member of a cursed clan of spirit world
warriors she's tasked with taking out a
yomu strange creatures that roam the
human world apparently there's an
immortal high schooler who happens to be
half yomu half human and this yomu is
beyond the boundary so to take out
beyond the boundary she'll have to take
him out hence the girl ends up at the
school she's on the roof when that same
boy akihito sees her he thinks that
she's about to jump so he rushes to the
roof and tells her that a cute glass is
wearing girl like i shouldn't die and
from there you guessed it folks this
dude has a glasses girl fetish and while
we won't be delving any further into
this specific sub-topic let's just say
he's quite hardcore about it mirai
immediately does a swing and stabs him
with a bloodsaver of course since he's
immortal he doesn't die though mirai
already knew about that the next few
days are mostly about her trying to kill
akihito whenever she gets the
opportunity and akihito is getting tired
of it because even though he won't die
he still feels pain so in return for
letting him off the hook he takes her to
a dinner and tells her how painful it
really is having to keep up with all
those sudden attacks but even though she
let him off the hook for today she will
attack again tomorrow it was still just
the beginning even though mirai's goal
is to kill him they're gradually getting
closer to each other one night when
akihito sees her injured because of a
fight with yomu he even helps her with
the band-aids of course he does mirai
meets with the head of the nase family
izumi as she advises her that she
shouldn't get too close with the target
when mirai meets akihito she tells him
how the blood running through her veins
is cursed and he simply tells her that
he's the same way things escalate very
quickly from here on out izumi has a
meeting with an interrogation officer
named miroku and they talk about a
hollow shadow this shadow also had quite
a history with mirai so akihito thought
that the reason she's here is because
she wants to kill it so by letting it
possess his body he helps mirai kill the
hollow unfortunately he knew nothing
about what mirai really wanted and he
overdid himself with this one the
younger brother of izumi appears
together with their teacher shizuku and
a spirit world warrior yet fox yomu
ayaka they helped contain his now messed
up disposition inside a barrier but
akihito's yomo nature gets the better of
them the barrier is destroyed and is
also not in control anymore when mirai
opens her eyes the other three have
passed out and in front of her is
akihito all possessed she runs towards
him and gives him a big hug which
somehow helps him revert back to his
human state and just like that they're
now even closer to each other though
this event was still the beginning of
what was to come next the yomu inside
akihito is a danger to everyone mirai
started getting more acquainted with the
youngest nase sibling mitsuki when
akihito is getting taken care of by
ayaka and ai sakura and mirai pay a
visit apparently just like how akihito's
yomu state was weakened because of what
happened his human state has also
weakened greatly when the two leave
sakura tells mirai how she can just stay
with akihito if that's what she wants
but she isn't so sure considering how
even if she was there she wouldn't know
anything about what to do so in search
of how she can help him and resolve the
beyond the boundary situation she and
the naase siblings are inside akihito's
apartment i know i said i'm not going to
talk anymore about the glasses girl
fetish but man the guy was even taking
notes after notes on how mirai looked in
glasses and trust me there's plenty of
them later mirai talks to izumi all
alone in a cafe and she tells her about
a way she can help akihito recover and
the beyond the boundary situation will
also be resolved however she'd be using
her own body to contain the yomu instead
so there's no telling what would happen
if she did that mirai understands but
she's ready to do it at least this way
akihito stand by he won't have to die so
it happens she faces off against beyond
the boundary in the spirit world and
with all those memories creating all
sorts of emotions inside her and an epic
song playing in the background she does
it akihito wakes up from his slumber he
was in a coma all this time he sees
mirai sitting by his side in those red
glasses he always adored and so the
summer days continue but unfortunately
before long the man must come face to
face with a rather shocking realization
while he and mirai in the club room she
tells him what happened the yomu that
was inside of akihito and how she got
rid of it but as her own body absorbed
the yomu she simply disappeared the
mirai standing in front of him right now
isn't there after all what akihito has
been seeing all this time was nothing
but a dream so when akihito wakes up
this time for real only mirai's glasses
are on the seat it was the truth she had
indeed disappeared the young narse
siblings tell him the same thing about
how she simply vanished when he
encountered izumi he realizes how it was
her who told mirai about this way the
man is now depressed with a sad face
he's on his way home one of mirai's
familiar sakura asks him about mirai but
he has no answer when he's home he takes
a good look at his phone and stumbles
across a message by mirai a message he
sent before heading out to deal with
beyond the boundary it simply stated how
he can live and die like a normal person
now and how she doesn't find it
unpleasant a meaningful word considering
how mirai's catchphrase is calling
everything unpleasant anyways this only
increases his depression but when
something supernatural happens the we
can and beyond the boundary simply
retreated into another dimension to
battle mirai while simultaneously
absorbing the supernatural energy from
the real world there's a giant orb-like
dimension in the sky and the guys are
suddenly outside there's akihito running
toward it only to be stopped by sakura
the younger nazi siblings also show up
and the teachers there too and to top it
off they have letters stating how mirai
is still alive and need to meet up in
the club room so they all head over
there apparently it was akihito's mother
who sent those letters so we can see her
enter the club room in the most uncanny
and bold way a mother can she uses a
mecca to enter and once outside she's in
a usual flashy outfit she explains how
not only is mirai alive she's fighting a
long strenuous battle inside that bubble
they saw in the sky she's up against
beyond the boundary and if the yomo were
to win it may very well spark the end of
the world and that's why this situation
just can't be ignored now using a yomu
stone which was created during mirai's
clash would be on the boundary he's
going to head up there and help her his
mother also tells him about a puppet
version of akihito which mirai's strong
emotions ended up creating it's also
inside that bubble and he's got to catch
that too he finally asks her how she
knows all of this to which his mother
simply dodges the question he leaves by
telling her how he expects all the
answers someday just then izumi also
enters the seed and tells akihito to
stop after all remember he is no longer
immortal but he tells her how he's
willing to do anything for a
bespectacled beauty and so it begins as
a melon dramatic song plays in the
background and the visuals hasten
akihito dashes forth jumps up and
reaches for the place mirai has been
fighting inside all alone all this time
once inside he grabs her and hugs her
with all of his might she asks him why
he's come by doing so he just spilled
water all over everything she'd done but
he's even more emotional he never wanted
her to sacrifice herself in the first
place he would never want a future with
her by his side why couldn't she
understand that he refuses to accept
what she was doing for the first time he
tells her how it was her who was being
rather unpleasant so left with no choice
but to fight the now enraged beyond the
boundary together akihito prepares
himself to take on all the emotions he
had been suppressing this whole time
when his own darkness emerges in front
of him he simply asks her to shut her
eyes and when she's asked to open them
back there's an insane almost ridiculous
number of yomu so they got a fight and
finally akihito fights beyond the
boundary or rather he fights himself and
takes the yomu back inside him thus in
turn going back to who he was before but
only this time he's accepted the
darkness in his heart and is now content
with his existence during the final
moments when the two have taken care of
things mirai is shedding tears as she
puts his hand on her head and asks him
to pad she ends up vanishing just like
that yet again things settle down and
everyone goes back to their lives
akihito keeps reminiscing about mirai
holding her blood ring in his hand
though as he's on his way back from
school after a hard day something
unexplainable happens he rushes to the
roof and finds mirai standing there in
silence she isn't wearing her glasses so
he presents them to her little did he
know
this wasn't the end but another
beginning that's right folks now for the
next few minutes let's talk about what
happens next aka the sequel movie it's
been one year since what happened on
that day of course mirai is returned but
as it turns out she's lost all of her
memories of those incidents akihito or
any of her past akihito and mitsuki
continue to watch over in the club room
they're the only two members left since
mitsuki's brother has graduated akihito
is emotionally stressed but he sees this
is better for mirai's sake now she won't
have to live with her painful pastor can
simply start a new life
though when sakura asks her about which
club she wants to join she ends up
replying the literature club and when
she asks if it's because of akihito she
blushes even though she may not have the
memories the real mirai was still inside
there she tries reaching out to akihito
but he pretends that they never knew
each other and continues to avoid her
but this wasn't all when mirai is on her
way together with sakura they're
attacked by shadows and a hooded one
directly asks mirai if she knows who she
is
unfortunately akihito and hiroomi save
the day before things get ugly mirai
continues to try and ask akihito but
sakura mitsuki and hiromi continue to
tell her that he's just a weird pervert
with a thing for girls who wear glasses
though they couldn't have hidden the
truth for long considering how mirai
ends up becoming aware of her blood
powers mirai ends up becoming the vice
president of the literature club it's
omitsuki and akihito can protect her
from the hooded figure meanwhile hiromi
meets up with ayaka and i he's now
taking over the nasa household
considering how izumi is nowhere to be
found ayaka is rather concerned because
he's not as strong as his sister anyway
they needed to do something about those
shadows and that hooded figure sakura
tells akihito that it isn't of any use
mirai's curiosity of a past just keeps
on increasing he meets with her himself
and further stresses his glasses fetish
but mirai just ends up using her same
old catchphrase it's unpleasant this was
emotional for akihito considering how
the real mirai was still inside later as
they're in the same part where they
shared a connection in the past mirai
tells him about her blood ability and
wonders if this is the reason why they
can't be together though before the
conversation gets any deeper the hooded
figure appears but mirai's blood prowess
ends up melting her hoodie that's in
turn revealing her identity it's izumi
she grabs mirai's face looks her in the
eye and says that she'll tell her who
she really is hiromi also appears and
the situation gets weirder though izumi
doesn't hold back in her attacks and
disappears after causing trouble we then
see a scene where izumi is kneeling in
front of another hooded figure when the
situation clears up for the time being
and akihito is back home he's greeted by
his mother and after the usual gag she
states how she'll help him with the
izumi situation ayaka is going to have
to intervene considering how the older
two nazi siblings are now going to kill
each other back to mirai she's at her
apartment when akihito shows up at her
door he wants to talk but when she's
ready to leave with him she receives a
call from akihito telling her that they
must meet as it turns out the akihito at
her doorstep was fake it's the
interrogation officer miroku and the man
who's been pulling the strings he takes
time to manipulate mirai into thinking
that her original objective was to kill
beyond the boundary and it hasn't
changed even now meanwhile in a forest
hiromi and ayaka take on izumi it's a
tough dilemma everything about izumi
raises further questions ayaka is ready
to face her off instead of making her
brother kill her older sister she just
teleports him as for mirai she keeps
getting consumed by darkness akihito is
making his way there mitsuki and shizuku
also arrive they're trying to hold her
off but they can't before long the fight
drags to the same place as izumi and the
others as for the other hooded figure
he's apparently using izumi as a vessel
and reveals that all those shadows
aren't yomu they're actually spirit
world warriors who succumb to darkness
and if nothing's done the same will
happen to mirai speaking of mirai or
should i say evil mirai she's still
trying to kill akihito in her mind she
sees her brother reminding her how their
purpose in life is to kill beyond the
boundary but before she can finish
akihito hiromi attacks her giving an
amazing visual fight as this goes on
ayaka is defeated and she's seen falling
from above fortunately hiromi is
successful in talking some sense into
izumi well she's also a victim in all of
this after all considering how she was
also manipulated by that hooded figure
and then finally we get to the climax
akihito fends off as mirai repeatedly
tries to kill him he keeps wondering
about how to get through to her and then
suddenly something clicks he lets her
wound him and then uses that ring as a
connection of some sort and he himself
enters her subconsciousness he sees
everything how she and her mother were
persecuted for being from the cursed
clan the hatred she always had to deal
with and the pain that came together
with it the only way to get her out of
that darkness was love so he does it
again he confesses his love and swears
to protector no matter the situation or
circumstance and just like that mirai
comes to terms with her past in the
aftermath of this scene we see ayaka and
izumi who are still alright but
unconscious the reason why akihito's
mother knows so much is because she's a
gage keeper between the two worlds and
it's her job to keep watch life returns
to normal once again mirai and akihito
are now lovebirds and akihito is now a
chad who says he loves mirai even when
she's without her glasses so there you
have it that was the storyline of the
two beyond the boundary movies i do want
to hear your thoughts on this movie so
don't forget to rate the comment section
well then with that said be sure to
subscribe for more and i'll see you in
the next video